Michael Cudlitz is here Michael welcome
to the show man how are you awesome how
you doing it's good to see you well it's
an exciting time to be you you've got
The Kids Are Alright
Tuesday's at 8:30 on ABC now when you uh
when you find out that your you're
getting killed off the walking dead why
are you gonna go right there no I know I
know it's not morning there was now who
died Wow but but do you sit there and
you go like Oh what the [ __ ] I don't I
don't need to get killed off this show I
don't have anything lined up for what's
next this was it everybody knew my
handlebar mustache it was good I was
good with it
yeah yeah I've been I've had a nice
little run I fell in love I was happy
and it was time to die did you get sick
of it at all if not the people but the
idea of the car I'm ready to do
something new no actually the people are
the only thing I did get sick oh no it
was it was awesome get you separated you
know for most of us out there we
separated from her family so we shoot in
Georgia and I think there were two or
three the cat of the regular cast
members that actually lived out there
but everybody else is brought in from
out of town so you you kind of find a
really cool family bond because you're
all you have out there I mean the
weather I could choose better weather
sorry [ __ ] weather right yeah but
Atlanta was fantastic I loved Atlanta
yeah but being away from your family is
not the greatest thing in the world it
was all right I've twin boys that are 22
okay yeah do they go to college they do
tell me thank you were you on that list
did you pay the the 500 grand again we
have we'll have a couple minutes there's
some guys waiting downstairs does that
stuff boggle your mind when you go like
you know you went through this process
you got the kids into school and you're
like what I don't understand I did well
see the thing is I this like two part I
do understand like I understand that the
need or the want to do the best for your
kid what I don't understand is the all
the tremendous illegal things that then
continued from it when the
and the cheating on the test it's like
cheating at golf it's like yeah look if
you you don't know it you don't know it
right I don't eat it on the SATs you
know I guess because everyone thinks
that it's a rigged system anyway so they
kind of want to give everyone a pass but
no it's like they know the tax evasion
you know it's like it becomes like a
like your criminal but how do you have
that discussion I don't have kids but
how do you have that discussion with
your kid when you're like like if you
just do something and they don't know it
but how do you go alright look you have
there was some kid that they said to
talk slower in the psychiatric
evaluation sorry yeah you get a
moderator moderator you no longer like
nothing your special needs but that
you're like a little slow and you need
more time say how do you city your kids
just like you're not as bright so you
can get more time on the test how do you
have the tie to the school you want to
go to you like we're gonna screw these
people over okay mom yeah I mean mine
wouldn't mine are like they kind of like
to do everything on their own anyway
whatever it is there's elements of it I
don't understand at all yeah you would
think I mean to your point about the the
illegalities by like you know maybe step
one it starts to sound like oh it'd be
nice to have an advantage but by step
two you're like wait a minute we're
starting to go into this web of of
things that we're not going to be able
to get out of we should not do this I
think we all everyone agrees though or
knows it like that that system anyway
it's like well we buy a building we can
get in yeah most of us are not in a
position to do that but somehow that's
okay so it's this one so wing well their
kid getting because their legacy they're
just so much stuff built into the system
where you sort of go well oh if I figure
out a way that's okay then this is just
a more obvious version of what people
have been doing for years in college is
just like a more blatant example until
you go into and guess what you can write
it up on your taxes the donation yeah
yes tough yeah there is there's a legal
way to buy your way into college and an
illinois device makes it confusing
because then you go well you're rich but
you're not rich enough and everybody
else who doesn't even have the means to
even consider that it's sort of like
what the hell are you all talking about
yeah it is a more obvious way to write
people yeah my father went here and if
he's father than a powerful alumni and
it's okay yeah it's in a problem because
I give to the Alumni Association
exact you know you got that recurring
you got that recurring donation that
sets
you set it up when the kids are like 10
so by the time they're 18 we're good to
go
did you go to college I did point art
school okay I always laugh when I say
that I don't know why did I think
everyone else is laughing when I say it
I went to California Institute of the
Arts so do you feel badly I never
understood like that with the Alumni how
they get so attached to this it's just
let it go yeah you didn't jealous cuz
you didn't go to college
I did not no but I wouldn't go back
anyway I'll go back to my high school if
Ike if I couldn't have gotten into the
art school I wouldn't have gone to
college I mean I went to City College I
just would never I was never a great
student mm-hmm like ever what you think
in art school acting yeah yeah I love
looking at people's IMDB like the first
stuff they got yeah like from like you
for you why cuz you hope that one day
maybe you'll get something I know mine
is empty right now the auditions thank
you before this and that kissing your
butt trying to get in your college yeah
21 Jump Street like you did a lot of
like weekly shows you did like Chicago
Hope like episodic s-- NYPD Blue I'm
fascinated with this stuff like how long
did you did you do all these things we
were auditioning for one episode before
you finally nail something well it's
funny cuz like NYPD Blue it's been on
the air so long I think I'd addition for
my PD blue six or eight times before I
finally got cast what would you play
would you play first I was I was hired
to play this guy who had who Sipowicz
thought had had shaken his baby to death
but he hadn't but then they threw that
script out this is when David Milch was
there and they were rewriting you know
he would just be in the middle of a
story and toss it out and stay over that
can't be great for you and they look at
you and they go like no he can't play
the guy who didn't shake his baby yeah
no it's awesome
the material is fantastic but then I
wanna they toss that story on they wound
up hiring me like two days later to play
a white supremacist group that came into
New York and we were a bunch of old army
buddies and we we burned up one of our
other buddies because he had married a
person of color Wow earn the guy yeah
you only have to do that you know
yeah when you're a racist white guy with
a mono syllabic name yeah he's going get
my old friends up well he just shouldn't
have done what he did right Yeah right
God consequences have or actions have
consequences
exactly so at the end of it are you
caught have you arrested of course my PD
blue was right that was yeah the West
Jimmy Smith's a phenomenal phenomenal
actor there's a great time
what was the gig where you started to
feel like you had confidence not in your
ability but in the fact that you were
gonna be able to make a living doing
this because I would imagine when you're
doing episodes of series and going
you're making a living but there's no
guarantee that you're gonna be able to
continue there's no guarantee ever
honestly I mean I have five good buddies
who you know just stopped working
yeah I'm and that sounds really sad and
it is but he just go back to day jobs or
other yeah and I'd started out doing
construction in film and television
that's right paid my way through school
and if I had to go back to do it again I
would know at points right you working
behind the scenes while you were acting
as well yeah until Band of Brothers was
kind of the big transition where was I
don't I don't think I thought okay I
don't have to you know I don't worry
about working again but I moved into a
place where I didn't have to worry about
right you know I mean work kept coming
up no paranoia is healthy like
everything yeah you got it
okay this last gig enjoy it yeah well so
that's it yeah when you're ready when
you're when you're okay like story line
wise I'm ready for my my role on The
Walking Dead to be done it makes sense
that it would be done here but
monetarily and in terms of getting a
check every week isn't there a part of
you that goes like oh no what's next
yeah yeah hundred percent yeah if you're
not you're an idiot
in my opinion if you're not sort of
thinking hmm if I leave the handlebar
stash on I can do Comic Cons pretty are
you doing next I don't care I don't
think anyone like you know I don't think
anyone's thinking that way what you do
on 21 Jump Street played a boxer dude
who
they kill somebody probably kill
somebody probably think so yeah they
killed some butter Leon I killed a lot
of people you did yeah I give a lot of
people later on to every joke they wanna
you know so that's about right that's
why I chose to do the new project kids
are all right because it's kind of tired
of killing people but you're still a
working-class gruff dude even and the
kids are all right whoa whoa whoa my
loving caring father that you obviously
have misunderstood oh maybe maybe the
nuance was lost on me I haven't seen it
so you play it do you play a gruff guy
or do you play I do it it's these it's
we're an Irish Catholic family there's
eight kids all boys and you you know you
got a rule with a semi-metallic
fist so I mean part of it is you know
you know the working class mentality and
just getting the kids through what they
need to get through don't worry about
you know so getting the parents through
with the parents you know it's like you
know where you don't really have time to
worry about the kids were your well your
parents supportive of you being in the
arts you know you were you grew up in
Long Island I grew up born in Long
Island grew up mostly in New Jersey we
moved out of New York when I was five
and then we were in New Jersey and Lake
was for another ten eleven years that
I've done gigs there whereas Lake was
not like Western jure I don't remember
like central beach community is shorted
by six flags all I was like I'm sorry
it's actually by okay how do you get to
Six Flags don't ask if you know a 16
year old kid how to get to 65 did you go
a lot or no we did either we had your
you know summer passes and that stuff I
was taught before I get very sick on
rides I do too you do yeah I can't
nothing so what would you do six bikes
just get sick and walk around yeah you
know meet girls meet girls never just
hang out so Eddie have siblings I do
have two brothers so where was everybody
was it like an artistic household or
were you just kind of the standout of
like no I liked his acting spot I'd like
the acting stuff
I never thought I would be able to make
it in yeah it was a blue-collar
community it was not really an option so
it wasn't sort of like I mean I liked
doing it but I thought okay I'll be able
to do this in Community Theatre or
whatever but not a the career was never
even on the radar you figured you have
your construction job and then you do
community theater and that would be that
exactly yeah do it on the side and then
you know when I can and probably
whatever there was no honestly there was
no when I was growing up there was no
thought that that was going to be the
thing so have you ever had it like was
there ever a game plan like here's my
strategy going in or was it wow this is
somehow working I'll just move on to the
next thing it kind of evolved and it was
like this is somehow working and then
when there was a point when I was going
to City College where my dad walked in
on me when I was gonna go to school for
engineering I was gonna transfer out to
an engineering school and he was like
what are you doing and it was basically
like well I'm doing my homework he's
like not what are you doing he's like
that Jen you know John Key's I can say
anything we're having this conversation
boxing sport of the future and I
basically told him you know I wanted to
do acting but I wasn't really an option
he was like well why throw away your
dream when you haven't even tried it
Wow yeah so I quit school the next day
which use are like what the hell and
then I applied to one school which is
Cal arts like I could not see myself
going to a regular College I just wasn't
I wasn't equipped for it at the time I
probably would have done fine later but
at the time was not equipped and then I
got in and had an awesome time there it
was incredibly incredibly beneficial to
me is your dad still living he is
oh he's seeing you all your success yeah
that's great yeah he's pretty awesome so
how do you apply to when you applied it
again I never applied to a college I
went to Middlesex community one semester
didn't go well
no no great the one professor is like
we're gonna give Jimmy a B because we
just wanted to pass through and all the
other professors are going this is
clearly an F it's they're like we don't
even know who this guy is
yeah I [ __ ] flopped in on
in problems and statistics Western
civilization and science or whatever
once you go to class and just fail
everything we're kind of most terrible
he doesn't even like suppose we were
like now I never went he's like now I
was there every day I still failed I
would apply myself properly but I did go
it was a high school / college courses
Jai dropped out of high school you know
taking remedial math I'm not remedial
math whatever is like the 101
yeah whatever 99 whatever is gr all
these stories about the high school kids
taking college classes in high school
yeah I took high school classes in
college transfer it to high school then
I can also use and like well these are
for you dope they're kind of like you
have your foot in high school at one
foot in college so there's so many
people in this class did you end up
failing the math class which meant that
you didn't get the high school credits
either no credit no high school credits
but maybe get my driver's license no
take the bus every day the middlesex
Community College and I would miss it
all the time so finally it motivated me
to get a driver's license silver lining
yeah there was a silver lines in the
driver's license I was very scared
that's good did you did you move out to
LA after college or did you live out
there at any point I moved out finished
my last year at high school actually in
Riverside California moved out to live
with my dad oh so he moved down there
yeah
that must have made it easier for you to
get into acting it did and that's
probably location was probably a huge
part of it had I stayed in New Jersey
I don't even though it's close to New
York obviously like what's farther
yeah well yeah but it's we're closer to
the city then you know being in Ohio or
something yeah yeah so will you do in
theater first do you member like the
first theater Shadid first yeah but
elementary school I remember my mom used
to make costumes for me I did like the
lot the Cowardly Lion in The Wizard of
Oz and I was Bert in Mary Poppins
did you do a good Cowardly Lion okay I
can't yeah I can if I were king
I just watch that again recently procs I
hadn't seen it in many many years and I
forgot there was so much of a lead up
before that she got blown out of into Oz
oh my god well it's gonna turn to color
it's gonna turn to color there was the
big thing man and a lot of people don't
remember that started in black and white
again in Kansas and then when she would
that was like it ah yes forever I get to
Colorado for crying out loud when are we
gonna get I forgot about that that he
meets the [ __ ] Wiz she meets the
wizard everybody
she taught now are you supposed probably
by design though because they didn't
want to have to colorize that much film
probably not they were just like let's
leave as much did now when she's uh
getting ready to beat no she's like
hanging out at the farm and [ __ ] and
be wasn't at me and I'm be probably amp
AC MPs I was giving everybody [ __ ] and
yelling at all the farmhands and then
you realize oh that's the Cowardly Lion
that's the Scarecrow that's the Tin Man
right are you supposed to recognize them
once you see them in Oz it's okay if you
do
I didn't I I remember remember you know
realizing it when she's like and you
were there and you were there and you
and you're like oh [ __ ] yeah I remember
going like oh no you're right right Tin
Man that was that guy with silver
charlie
but they show them a lot at first so I'm
wondering are you supposed to recognize
that or not I don't remember it's okay
if you do I think it's okay if you don't
and you get you at the end but if you do
not me at the end pretty good they did
yeah it did do you did you do musical
theater after it did so much musical as
an adult as well I thought it was an
adult no not as an adult just as like I
know one has done more singing and
dancing than me it meaning someone who
does not sing or dance huh I did so many
musicals when they were doing we didn't
do lame it's not like Oklahoma and
Pippin and Fiddler on the Roof and I
mean did you enjoy them I got did I I
don't care for musicals I didn't know I
couldn't sing or dance it seems like you
could because you got casting good role
when I was a school I did chorus I was
like the guy was there and then I was
hanging lights in between oh so you
weren't Burton Mary Poppins for all the
[ __ ] no I was in the third grade doing
that that you were good and that was
good but when it got into the dull stuff
I did a lot of musical theater with
singing and dancing which I do neither
I see so you were not great was the only
thing was available right yeah right
that makes it was like I'm going to
Broadway I'm like alright see you later
hey with you when you became a problem
this what you're doing was there
anything that they wanted you to
audition for that you didn't that you're
like [ __ ] there's a couple things ever
did Band of Brothers I was approached by
pretty much any kind of military thing
that came out you know that was even
close to to my age or body type and
there were some things that were not
done well not researched well that they
were trying to get me to do and I would
not do something that represented the
military in a way that was not accurate
I felt that having done Band of Brothers
that put the responsibility back on me
to because from now on I bring something
to the project that has the history of
these men with it yeah and there's a
responsibility that I have to honor
those men and those families and whether
it be real or imagined for me it's real
so that was about III remember it's been
many that was about World War two yeah
and at the end don't they show all the
real guys talking throughout this so I
started as say um it's about the hundred
first airborne and it's wrapped around
the actual that's at the interviews that
they did and the stories that they that
they they gave and it's based on the
book by Stephen Ambrose don't all those
guys to those those guys like War
veterans they talk about the one thing
that they wish I've heard them say that
maybe not there but they wish they had
been able to talk about it when they got
home because none of them talked about
they were all yea quiet and just shut up
about it wasn't it was a different war
yeah when you the Vietnam situation came
afterwards it was you know it was all
about talking about it and discussing it
and I think that you know that's why we
see this sort of raw emotion that comes
out of it with world war ii the sort of
feeling was okay we basically this is a
sort of the first time in a long time
anyway that there was an actual enemy we
knew what evil was it was Hitler we
defeated it okay come home we'll take
care of you well you know give you loans
pay for your school bury it let's not
talk about that and and they didn't you
know and I think that there was a lot of
damage done because of that yeah they
all just [ __ ] you do in a war and they
had no one to talk to about us they just
kind of swallowed us yeah we have many
many stories of families
soon after the the the parents or the
relatives saw Band of Brothers in
Washington you know the footlocker's
came out and they would take out the
uniforms and discussed like what they
did was talking about their buddies it
was it was pretty incredible to be part
of that
yeah really incredible actually yeah I
mean and and yeah I mean that seems like
the type of thing that if you do if you
can't talk about that because the
experience and I think that's why when
they're done right shows and movies
about the military and the experience is
so compelling is because it's so even
though it's for us and it's these people
are the people who are living right next
to us
it is so foreign that life is so foreign
to anything that we exist through it's
incredible and I don't think anybody can
appreciate it unless they've actually
lived it yeah you know I agree it's a
different breed people that are do
they're told like I was reading
something about like we were watching
something only was a Navy SEAL training
whatever was a team steel stitch
whatever it was you go through and that
and like the fact is like they keep
[ __ ] with you and at the end that you
think you're done like alright I
graduated and like alright you got to go
for a run and it's a [ __ ] like a
20-mile run it's like a three-month run
run pack your [ __ ] I've thought of that
when I was on the treadmill like how do
you relate well I see because sometimes
your trainer will be like five more
minutes but it's really seven but I'm
like that's illegally I don't think I
can do five more minutes out of ten
rockets and like what would I do if a
guy told me to run 20 my would just try
would just go I'm done I want to go home
yeah well that's why you're you're very
far from they got the Bell
yeah I would literally ran it on the way
in well if you had been born in the
greatest generation they probably would
have thrown you out they would English
his father would have given me that
speech in the game of Thrones
throw me the [ __ ] oh wow
you're not you're no longer in the
military you're no longer fighting
zombies now you get to be a family man
to be a family man raising children in
the 70s and there are you know you
definitely guys you guys draw
comparisons not right on the nose but
pretty close you're drawing comparisons
I feel like to what's going on now when
you bring up the Nixon stuff a little
bit oh I think so I think it's a great
reminder you know
whatever you know side of the aisle or
you know circle you sit on everybody
thinks like yeah this is the end like
this is the most horrible time we've
ever been through in it and the truth is
it's not it's like it's has this
happened before it happened many times
before and in the end we we do come out
of it and we do come out of it stronger
and it's I think it's a you know very
hopeful loving you know sort of look
back at where we were and comparing it
to where we are
you know without without you know
punching you in the head with it that's
a very good perspective on it too
because there are people that feel like
maybe because we're inundated with
content more now than we ever have been
that every time things are going bad
we're in the end of days and it's never
been this bad and it's realistic ly
exactly it's like over and over again so
yeah here's something if you catch
something when it first comes out it's a
headline you're like oh my gosh this
this bus blew up and then I you know
then my dad will be like four days later
oh my god did you hear a bus just blew
off and I'm like wait no that was
nothing that that it makes it okay that
a bus blew up but everything is like so
layered and happening on this you know
repeating cycle and it's over and over
again and there's like everybody's you
know when if you really sat down you
could sort of you'd make a list of ten
things and everybody's list would be the
same ten things of like you know shitty
things that have happened in the past
month right it's it's not like there's a
thousand things it's like no there's
these ten things that are on blast
so like turn off your phone you know
turn off the news feed like no get away
from it for a minute and there you know
you realize everything's not so bad talk
to the people that are you're just next
to you like they're just hanging out
with you yeah busted just blow up
actually it was I think you might be the
driver might have been killed it was a
gas explosion there's footage of it in
in Sweden or something was really weird
the bus just exploded but it wasn't an
attack when most of us aren't going
online searching for bus explosion I
look for it was just there it hit me in
that the bus the body you got you guys
said it to me
there it is it's just [ __ ] uh just
going and you're reading the ads so kind
of a natural gas thing and then the guy
films his leg good job you happen to be
filming him behind him just for you why
don't you film a bus for no reason be
the first guy I talked to
I'm just saying I played one on TV but
that guy I would want to talk to him
first what was 11th floor 11th hour 11th
hour was 11th hour that was a like a
medical drama I think about like it
would be like the CDC there was you know
the everybody was gonna die unless they
figured it out it was like you know
typical one-hour drama oh yeah it's so
you know tragic for 59 minutes and then
they hear you heroes the leads of the
show go I figured out oh thank god yeah
to do with communicable diseases and
stuff like that yeah you know what your
is that that's so far that's that's why
I'm asking cause it's just a random
thing in the middle like that I remember
it it's after the 10th and before the 12
what year was that it was a 2009 you
play Ben Finney of course I did yeah
sometimes Jim likes to have the IMDB
printed out so you can just point to
random things and go what's this doing
it's the most important thing in the
world I sure when you're auditioning for
stuff yeah [ __ ] I got this I'm so
psyched you're getting there and that's
your whole world is that day and then
it's just so unimportant it becomes
anyway no I remember stuff I'm probably
setting myself up for failure right now
but I remember like stuff that became
and sometimes the character name will
just come back and the whole event will
come back because it is so intense you
know I had a buddy who Frank John Hughes
who's a writer terrific Acuras and Band
of Brothers as well and he said you know
as a guest actor you're like required to
basically knock it out of the park every
time but so like if your honor if you're
in a regular cast you come in and you
can be sick you can have a bad day and
you get home the rearrange the schedule
but it's a guest cast you're like you
got to crush it short every time you
know and if you look like the Baseball
Hall of Fame you gotta like be good 50%
of the time and you're in the Hall of
Fame right if you're a 500 player
there's like oh my god you're amazing
but as a guest actors like 500 gets you
fired right she was like every time you
have to do well there they tend to be
the intense sort of really emotionally
laid Laden roles you know where all the
guest cast gets to you know knock your
brains out and the
regular sort of contemplate you know mm
interesting
who are you in lost was I lost I was
Michelle Rodriguez his partner in
flashbacks I started out as a beat cop
and then in the end I came back and did
another episode where I was a detective
and I actually sent Hugo to the is
insane asylum which is where he wanted
to be to be protected
Brian forgot my cell Rodriguez isn't
this yeah yeah man